(Casting)
"Like the truth is Aphro went
to the org and he said it's either me or
him."
"I mean Peter can be a dick and talk
bad about everyone that he wants to talk
bad about but ultimately I don't care."
"I feel like people have a really like
skewed perception of me and Aphro."
"I mean that's cool. If he wants to hate me that's fine."
"To me I feel like he gave up on me
as a friend and as a teammate."
"Organization thought it would be the
best decision moving forward only
because Peter brings people down more
often than not."
"I think we can all agree
that I'm way better off on TSM and I
think TSM wins, I win and CLG ultimately wins because if
they really hate me so bad then now they
don't have to deal with me."
Aphromoo wanted something different.
Doublelift's attitude was bringing down
the team and Aphro wanted to take a
leadership role for everyone. He wasn't
just the team's leader, he was their big
brother. He was Mr. CLG. This is his story
Zaqueri “Aphromoo” Black was born on September 8, 1992 in Whittier, California,
and took to video games at a young age.
Aphromoo played Diablo with his dad
and eventually moved to playing
competitive World of Warcraft even,
playing on LAN at BlizzCon. But Aphromoo eventually grew tired of PvP WoW
and turned to League of Legends.
Aphromoo started out as a streamer,
and gained  popularity thanks to his solid AD carry play and loud personality.
But Aphromoo wasn’t just a popular streamer, he played at a high level, and
pros quickly took notice. Unfortunately, none of them seemed to stick
and Aphromoo joined seven teams between 2011 and 2012.
In late 2012, Aphromoo switched from AD carry to Support, and though he was playing a less
active role, he was still just as good, and just as bombastic.
Aphromoo first joined CLG in
December 2012 as their starting support, sharing the bot lane with a man
considered the best AD Carry in North America, Doublelift.
(Casting)
CLG placed fourth that season, but fell to last place in the playoffs, forcing
them to win their spot in the LCS back through the promotion tournament.
"Now for CLG the stakes couldn't be higher.
On the line for Hotshot and crew is not
just a trip to the LCS but the very
existence of the team."
Despite Aphromoo’s talents, the team didn’t work, and he was the first to leave the team after they requalified.
Aphromoo says that he stepped down, that he couldn’t handle the
pressure that came with being relied on by his entire team. The pressure of
playing with someone as demanding as Doublelift.
CLG replaced Aphromoo with founding member Chauster in May. Aphro returned to
streaming and did that full-time until October, when he tried out for Team Curse
and made the team before getting a call from CLG’s mid laner Link.
"I talked to Link and I saw Doublelift in Solo Q
and we played bottom lane again. I played
support and I guess he remembered me
after that. 'Oh yeah this guy still plays the game I guess so.'"
Aphromoo was back on CLG, and back with Doublelift. The best AD carry in North
America was back with one of the league’s brightest young support players.
It seemed like the perfect match. But the pressure was still on.
"Aphromoo was already on the team before and they
brought him back so that he could play
with Doublelift once again, exciting a
lot of the fans."
Doublelift and Aphromoo quickly became one of the stronger bot lanes in NA, and
one of the most popular as well. As the years went on, they only got better and
their fandom grew even more.  The pair played up their friendship for the
camera, leaning on their personalities to create one of the most iconic
partnerships in League of Legends: Rush Hour.
"Why did you guys seem like you
wanted to throw that game so badly." "Well
Doublelift didn't please me last night so
I was pretty mad and usually I take out
my rage in bottom lane and we saw that
today.
But while Support is a selfless role, playing support for Doublelift is
an even more selfless act.
Doublelift is a hyper carry, which means
Aphromoo’s entire job was to set things up for his AD carry to succeed. No
roaming, no playmaking, no glory.
(Casting)
Both players had big personalities, but as they played together more, Aphromoo’s
started to mellow out. Where Doublelift got louder, Aphromoo
started taking a more quiet leadership role on the team, taking on shotcalling
duties and even getting more pensive in interviews.
"What are you guys looking at as kind of your real opponents right now and who's gonna give you some trouble
final question." "Honestly I don't really
talk down most of the teams in league
they're really good and really fun to
play against." "Good policy." "Especially
Enemy as you've seen right here.
TSM, Team Liquid, Dignitas, Enemy and
that's all I can think of right now
they're all looking really good and
they're really fun to play against and
that's all that really matters and we
just have to execute our plan as well as
we can."
The shotcalling position was taking its toll on Aphromoo. Every season, CLG’s team looked strong, but they never
quite managed to put together a win in the playoffs.
(Casting)
The pressure on Aphromoo was
mounting as his team looked to him to lead them to victory. He was still the
same fun-loving guy he was on stream all those years ago,
but on stage, he was a professional. And he wanted to win.
In Summer 2015, Aphromoo finally got his wish.
CLG looked better than ever. They placed second in the regular season, and went
undefeated in the playoffs, where they beat Team SoloMid 3-0 in the Grand Finals.
(Casting)
You’d expect Aphromoo to be ecstatic. You’d expect him to be happy.
But Aphromoo was just relieved. "I was
just like whatever. I think I relish in
the fact that I know all my teammates
are happy that we won. More so than,
you know me being happy that we won. You
know I just like seeing them you know
excited and I'm happy that you know all
the work that we put in you know we got
to where we went."
CLG went on to Worlds after their win at MSG, but failed to make it out of their group. And things were only going
get tougher for Aphromoo. "Hey my name is
Doublelift and starting today I'll be a
part of TSM." Doublelift’s departure wasn’t necessarily his own decision.
Aphromoo was the one who called for a shakeup in CLG. "Like the truth is Aphro
went to the org and he said it's either
me or him." "Great branding, one of the most
popular players in the league, has a
great franchise, you know, but the trade
off just wasn't that good." "I'm not ever
gonna deny that I made a lot of mistakes
but the thing is that I tried really
hard to fix them and I was getting
better and improving and there's like
interviews and a lot of proof where my
teammates and coach had said that I made
a lot of progress and I wasn't just
trying to improve I was improving."
"We tried to for three years. I was on the team
for three years obviously. And you know
get better little by little attitude you
know but team chemistry-wise and the
impact he had on the team in general
just atmosphere-wise, being in a personal
relationship with people is just it just
brings people down you know every season."
Aphromoo was given control of a new CLG team for the upcoming spring season, and
was preparing to lane with a fresh faced AD carry Stixxay.
Stixxay was young and new to the pro scene. He had played in challenger, but Aphromoo was the one who
shepherded him on to the big stage.
"So when Stixxay came to play he was very calm
mellow and when I play with him in lane
he would kill somebody who I didn't
think we would kill I was like what the
hell dude."
I didn't know you could get that guy, that was insane."
Aphromoo saw Stixxay as a younger
brother, but he also had plenty to learn from him. Breaking free of Doublelift’s
play and attitude let Aphromoo come into his own as a playmaker and shotcaller
(Casting)
CLG’s roster was unproven but with
Aphromoo at the helm
CLG quickly became one of the best teams
in the league that season. He was proving
that it wasn’t just Doublelift carrying CLG, he was an important part of the team’s
success as well.
(Casting)
Aphromoo led CLG to another NA LCS championship, this time
with a 3-2 win over TSM in the spring 2016 grand finals.
(Casting)
And CLG wasn't done. The
team went to the Mid-Season Invitational after playoffs, where they were pegged as
as one of the weaker teams at the event.
"So the thing about CLG is I actually don't
think they're a bad team, I just have
questions about their team on the
international stage and I think there's
three of them. Can Xmithie step up the way he
did in the finals. He diversified his
champion pools very well, not only
supportive but also very aggressive but
Stixxay, Huhi, I think that there are
huge questions about Huhi, he doesn't
get banned out very much what else can
he play. And Stixxay's champion pool
to me, I don't know whether it's good or
bad but it's bizarre man." But Aphromoo led CLG to second place, taking games off
of Royal Never Give Up, the Flash Wolves, G2 Esports and SK Telecom T1 in the process.
(Casting)
Aphromoo wasn’t sad about the
loss. In fact, he said it was an opportunity to learn and understand
where he had to lead his team to next. "We
definitely learned a lot and being able
to play against all the teams and making
it all the way to finals we have a lot
of knowledge that we can use for our
play and going into NA LCS I think that
NA as a region will probably do a lot
better at Worlds this time around
definitely really confident in saying
that." Aphromoo proved once again that, no
matter what his team looks like, no matter who his opponents are, he was the
stabilizing, leading presence teams need to make championship runs.
For his part, Aphromoo continued to get more and more measured in his public
appearances. He could still crack a joke, but being the guy his teammates relied
appearances. Being the most respected leader in the NA LCS made Aphromoo more pensive,
more thoughtful. "I don't think too much
has changed like with his personality
throughout the two or three years I've
known him. He's been pretty much the same
person but now he's a lot more like
commanding or like demanding of like
what he really wants and as far as like
gameplay or anything like that goes
before he was less of a natural leader
and now he's like a very like powerful
person within the team." As the seasons passed, Aphromoo stuck with CLG. Others came
and went, but Aphromoo was always there. He was Mister CLG, the team leader, the
company man, always there as the star support and leader the team looked to
when things looked rough. But CLG wasn't
winning championships anymore Aphromoo
needed a shake-up
and when NA LCS franchising hit, new
teams were knocking at his door. "I never
you know looked at my other options
besides CLG since I thought that that
would be my home forever but here we are."
100 Thieves wanted a star support. They wanted a great leader who could
show a brand new organization the way. They wanted experience and a stabilizing
presence. They wanted Aphromoo. "We are so
incredibly proud and excited to welcome
Aphromoo as the support player for the
100 Thieves' roster moving into the 2018
LCS. We got Aphromoo!
While they’re still a young team, 100 Thieves have done well so far. They’ve
beaten CLG, with Aphromoo leading them to victory.
(Casting)
But most importantly, Aphromoo has become the kind of veteran that he
looked up to all those years ago. "Stixxay,
who you essentially helped train and
grow, was playing against him a proud dad
moment or was it a I'm gonna put this
kid in his place." "Trevor is a good kid. He
actually has really good mechanics it
was really hard to land a skill-shot on
him. Usually I have that on my team from
playing on CLG right but uh CLG's
gonna do well. They are a new team coming
together from the jungle and support
roles as well but they just need a
little bit of time they'll be fine." He has one of the longest careers in North
American League of Legends, and has gone from a goofy streamer to one of the most
respected shot callers in the league. We don’t know how long Aphromoo will keep
playing, but he’ll always have a place as one of the North American League of Legends most important figures.
He might not have dozens of trophies, but he has something just as important: the respect that comes with being the ultimate support.